on the 9th of August 1999 Russia's
president Boris Yeltsin announced a new
acting prime minister most Russians had
never heard of him and in a poll just
two percent said that they'd vote for
him to become president exactly one
month after yeltsin's announcement a
massive explosion in an apartment
building just half an hour's drive from
the Kremlin killed more than 100 people
less than four days after that another
apartment bombing less than four miles
away killed 119 people the morning after
the second bombing the speaker of the
Russian Parliament paid tribute to the
victims that had died in the city of
volgodons but he'd made a mistake Volga
donk is 700 miles away from Moscow where
the bombing had actually happened so
when a car bomb actually exploded in
volgodonsk three days later things got
even weirder but there was no time for
questions Russia was under attack the
new prime minister quickly ordered a
massive bombing campaign against
separatists in the war-torn region of
chechnya even declaring that we'll waste
them in the Outhouse six months later
the new Prime Minister was elected
president by a grateful Russian Nation
his name was Vladimir Putin and since he
took power he has not let go he has had
his enemies killed started Wars and
destabilized the global order but for
someone so dangerous and so important we
know surprisingly little about him who
is Vladimir Putin really why did he
invade Ukraine what's the real story
behind those apartment bombings and why
is he actually weaker than ever
the Moscow apartment bombings are a key
part of Vladimir Putin's rise to power
and don't worry I'm going to talk more
about them but to truly understand how
he became the man he is today you need
to understand the organization that
molded him the case kdb the KGB was one
of the main instruments of Soviet state
power it operated Totally Above the Law
spying on dissidents tearing out
Espionage and acting as a secret police
force and because the Soviet Union had
lots of enemies the KGB needed lots of
Agents one of the best places to find
them was in the country's most
prestigious universities that's exactly
where they found a young law student at
Leningrad State University named
Vladimir Putin they waited until he
graduated before recruiting him in 1975.
lots of KGB agents joined because they
basically had no choice when your
country's notorious spy agency asks you
to join it's kind of hard to say no but
Putin joined because he wanted to he
spent his first few years with KGB
pushing papers in a gloomy office in
Leningrad but his first Big Break
arrived when in the early 1980s he was
summoned to Moscow to attend the
agency's elite foreign intelligence
training institute that's right it was
basically a professional development
course for Soviet spies after he learned
how to be a better spy Putin was
assigned to Dresden deep in the heart of
East Germany as the boundary between
communism and capitalism East Germany
was a rich source of Cold War Intrigue
and information this is building number
four Angelica strassa today it's the
regional HQ for an esoteric spiritual
movement but during the Cold War it was
the local KGB station and for the last
five years of the 1980s it was Vladimir
Putin's office his mission was to
recruit Communist party and Stasi
officials compromise visiting westerners
and travel undercover to West Germany it
also involved stealing Western
technology despite being first to space
and shocking the West with Sputnik by
the 1980s the Eastern Bloc was lagging
way behind the West after five years in
Dresden Putin returned to Russia and to
his old University in Leningrad even
though his cover story was that he
worked as an aide to the dean everyone
knew that Putin was still working for
the KGB spying on and recruiting
students of course there wouldn't be a
next generation of crack KGB spies
working undercover to steal Western
technology and NATO Secrets because the
Soviet Union collapsed in 1991 brought
undone by failed reforms and the
pressure of trying to keep up with the
United States Putin could see the end
coming before it arrived by then he'd
quit the KGB to go work for one of his
old law professors a guy named Anatoly
subchach subchach was one of the leading
voices calling for Democratic reforms in
the Soviet Union after the Cold War
ended he was elected mayor of Leningrad
which by then had reverted to its
original name of Saint Petersburg Putin
got a job working for sub check at City
Hall and he saw how bad things really
were the decline in living standards in
Russia after the cold war is hard to
comprehend life expectancy at Birth
plunged by more than five years between
1990 and 1994. things got so bad that
there are stories of people paying for
things with bricks because they were
worth more than Russian rubles at the
time even for the millions of Russian
people who by the end hated the
Communist system the collapse of the
Soviet Union brought chaos and
humiliation Russians went from living in
a country that went toe-to-toe with the
United States as a superpower to needing
handouts after his boss Anatoly sobchak
was voted out in 1996 Putin went to
Moscow there for reasons that have never
really been explained he suddenly
started moving up really fast in his
career he got a job in the presidential
Property Management Department at the
Kremlin it sounds like a boring admin
job but it actually gave Putin lots of
Leverage to Grant or turn down favors to
other political insiders he must have
done a lot of effective networking
because his next job after that was as
Deputy Chief of Boris yeltsin's
presidential staff he was obviously busy
but he still somehow found the time to
get what's basically the Russian
equivalent of a PhD in economics Putin's
dissertation was about maximizing the
value of mineral resources in his home
region it's more than 200 pages of
discussion about stuff like the quality
of gravel pits in Russia there are real
questions about whether he even wrote it
but believe it or not Putin's PhD wasn't
really about education it was about
ticking the boxes he needed in order to
keep advancing in his career after
working for Yeltsin Putin became
director of the FSB the intelligence
agency which replaced the k GB how did
Putin go from being a mid-ranking KGB
officer in East Germany to running the
successor agency less than 10 years
later maybe there's no conspiracy here
maybe he was just really great at time
management and really great at all the
jobs he was given or maybe his bosses
really liked the dissertation he wrote
but if you worked in Russian politics at
the time you could only climb the ladder
as quickly as Putin did if someone even
higher wanted it to happen however he
did it Putin quickly earned yeltsin's
trust his timing was perfect after 30
years in Soviet and Russian politics
which included surviving a coup Yeltsin
was done he was extremely pessimistic
about the problems Russia faced and his
bad Health which was exacerbated by his
drinking meant that he just didn't have
the energy to try and fix them so yeltin
believed his final act in public life
should be to choose the right successor
someone who could do what he had failed
to do rebuild Russia into a world power
he had a few candidates in mind one of
them was his Deputy Premier Boris namsov
namsov was very different from Putin for
start he had years of actual political
leadership experience having served as a
provincial governor and Member of
Parliament he was also by the standards
of Russian politics a liberal Democrat
instead of looking to the Past for ideas
on how to reform Russia he looked to the
West at one stage Boris Yeltsin
introduced him to Bill Clinton as his
chosen successor everything appeared to
be on track until fate intervened
the day the ruble fell 20 Vogue magazine
held a party for four thousand Financial
crises are complicated this one is no
exception the basic story is that
another Market crisis this one
originating in Asia reduced the price of
Commodities like oil gas and metals that
the Russian economy was dependent on as
the country's Revenue sharply decreased
so did its ability to repay its debts
which were mostly in the form of bonds
held by Foreign investors on August 17
1998 the Russian government defaulted on
its debts and was forced to devalue the
ruble it was a disaster for millions of
Russians Yeltsin sacked the Prime
Minister and his entire cabinet but even
that didn't contain the Fallout Boris
nemsov had staked his political
legitimacy on making Russia's economy
look more like the West so when it
collapsed he got blamed he went from
receiving more than 50 percent in a
presidential poll to being one of the
most hated men in the country in
addition to killing nemsov's hopes of
being yeltsin's successor the financial
crisis accelerated yeltsin's desire to
find a replacement and stand down and
eventually just one real Choice remained
Vladimir Putin but Yeltsin and his inner
circle had a problem
the public had no idea who Putin was it
was one thing to name him prime minister
Yeltsin could do that no problem but
Russia was meant to be a democracy and
in a democracy you can't just snap your
fingers and make someone the president
they actually had to win an election
Putin had no profile he wasn't a
reformer like nemsov if people had even
heard of him they probably Associated
him with the KGB if Russian Elites
wanted him to win an election they
needed people to know who he was which
brings us back to those bombings I
mentioned at the start of the video
they're a key part of Vladimir Putin's
rise to power so let's construct a
timeline
on the 9th of August 1999 Boris Yeltsin
named Vladimir Putin acting prime
minister 26 days later on the night of
September 4th 1999 a truck blew up a
barracks in bunatsuk a Garrison town on
Russia's border with the Breakaway
region of chechnya just after midnight
on September 9th a bomb went off in the
basement of an apartment building in
southeast Moscow the FSB the internal
security agency that until recently had
been run by Vladimir Putin reported that
items removed from the scene contained
traces of TNT and another explosive
called RDX government officials started
blaming Chechen terrorists for the
attack almost immediately just after
midnight on September 13th authorities
were called to check on reports of
suspicious activity at an apartment
building less than four miles away from
the previous bombing site they didn't
find anything but just a few hours later
a massive Car Bomb destroyed a
nine-story building on the cashier
Sequoia highway three days later another
bomb blew up near an apartment building
in the southern city of volgedansk the
whole nation terrified on the evening of
September 22nd several residents from
the city of razan about 120 miles
Southeast of Moscow saw a white sedan
pull up in front of their apartment
building
the car's license plate had been altered
the residents also noticed two men
removing several large sacks from the
trunk and carrying them into the
basement before driving away at speed
when local police arrived they found
three large sacks wired to a Detonator
and explosive timer the bomb was defused
and sent away for testing the next
morning the 23rd Putin congratulated the
local residents on their vigilance and
lauded the security forces for foiling
what could have been another deadly
attack that same evening police
apprehended the men who'd been seen
loading the sacks into the basement when
they were questioned they produced FSB
identification cards remember the FSB is
the agency that ultimately replaced the
KGB and Vladimir Putin before he became
prime minister was the FSB director a
short time later A call came from FSB
headquarters the men were to be released
the next morning September 24th the
director of the FSB appeared on national
TV suddenly the story had changed it
wasn't a foiled terrorist attack it was
an FSB training exercise meant to test
public awareness and the sacks in the
basement didn't contain explosives they
just had sugar in them the FSB was
trying to sweep the whole incident under
the rug and it might have worked until
the results came back from the lab the
analysis which was conducted by the
local branch of the FSB showed that the
sacs actually contained RDX the same
explosive that was found at the scene of
the bombing at gurinova Street two weeks
earlier but RDX wasn't something you
could make at home in fact there was
only one place you could get it in all
of Russia a heavily guarded facility in
the city of perm near the Ural Mountains
and about 1500 miles from chechnya
[Music]
it's details like this that make the
official story that the bombings were
all orchestrated by Chechen terrorists
hard to believe but the time for asking
questions was over because at the same
time as Putin was praising the residents
of razan for their bravery Russian
warplanes were already launching massive
airstrikes on the capital of chechnya
ordinary Russians were scared their
country had gone from being a superpower
to a basket case people were going
hungry losing their savings and dying in
their homes Vladimir Putin promised an
end to the chaos under him order would
be restored people didn't know about the
gaps in the official story or if they
did they pretended not to notice on
March 26 2000 Vladimir Putin was elected
president with 53 percent of the vote
the people of Russia might not have
realized it but they just made a very
fateful decision Russia at the present
time is at a crossroad the Communists
have been defeated but the ideas of
Freedom now are on trial Putin's first
major crisis came less six months into
his presidency this is the curse a
nuclear-powered Oscar 2 class submarine
at the time it was the biggest cruise
missile submarine in the world it was
said to be virtually Unsinkable so it
was the obvious choice to lead Russia's
first major Naval exercise in more than
10 years these exercises were basically
a way for Vladimir Putin to show
adversaries like nato in the United
States that after tumultuous few years
Russia was once again a military power
at about 11 A.M on August 12 2000 deep
in the barren sea the crew of The Curse
were given clearance to launch two dummy
Torpedoes at the Peter the Great battle
cruiser but the Torpedoes detonated
prematurely at 11 29 a.m nearby
Norwegian seismic detectors registered
an explosion two minutes later another
much larger explosion was detected the
Kursk sank to the seabed amazingly the
U.S defense secretary William Cohen knew
about the accident before the Kremlin
the International Community quickly
offered assistance to try and save any
crew who might still be alive but the
Russian government refused all offers of
help publicly they said they had
everything under control in reality they
knew the curse and its crew were in big
trouble it took 16 hours to locate the
Kursk after it sank and two days before
officials publicly acknowledged that
anything was wrong when they did they
said it was just experiencing minor
technical difficulties in truth any crew
members who survived the initial blast
were rapidly running out of air where
was Vladimir Putin in all this well he
was on vacation he actually wasn't even
informed the accident until the day
after it happened the Navy kept telling
him that they had it under control and
that there was a strong possibility that
the accident had been caused by a NATO
vessel if the cover-up was bad the
rescue attempts were even worse the
Russian Navy repeatedly failed in their
attempts to get into the submarine from
his seaside resort Putin finally agreed
to accept outside help but it was too
late by the time Norwegian divers
finally opened a hatch to the submarine
there were no survivors on August 21st
the Russian Navy finally forced to admit
the truth to the public the Russian
media strongly criticized the government
responses inept and their explanations
as totally unreliable Putin decided to
meet with family members a full 10 days
after the sinking access to the meeting
was tightly controlled State media's
broadcast of the meeting showed only
Putin speaking but inside the reaction
was furious two journalists who got in
by posing as family members witnessed
distraught widows and mothers screaming
at the president and demanding to know
who would be punished for the disaster
50 Cent
s when one extremely emotional mother
wouldn't stop interrupting a nurse
popped up behind her and forcibly
injected her with a sedative Days Later
Larry King asked Putin what happened
this is how he reacted
the cursed Fiasco was terrible for Putin
because it challenged the main part of
his appeal keeping Russians safe and
restoring the country's status as a
great power great Powers don't lose
their best ships and training exercises
and his response made it look like he
didn't really care about the people who
died or the effect it had on their
families still for the first few years
of his presidency most world leaders
either didn't see that side of Putin or
didn't care I found it to be very
straightforward
and trustworthy I am confident that this
new level of cooperation between NATO's
members and Russia will now change the
world and for the bit was Putin the KGB
Mastermind just tricking these world
leaders into thinking he was a good guy
I think the truth is much more
complicated and a lot of it has to do
with NATO remember NATO was created in
order to contain Soviet influence in
Europe so after the end of the Cold War
most people believed the alliance had
served its purpose Western policymakers
didn't see any real reason to keep
expanding it they preferred to focus
their energies on encouraging Russia to
become a democratic capitalist country
but that began to change in the
mid-1990s now we have to finish what
America started four years ago welcoming
Hungary Poland and the Czech Republic
into our alliance if you look around at
who's in the room today you can see that
they are more than willing Eastern
European countries which had spent
decades under Soviet influence were
suspicious of Russia's long-term motives
they wanted to join while Russia was
still weak because they knew it wouldn't
be weak forever polish officials even
told a team of researchers that if you
don't let us into NATO we're getting
nuclear weapons and Bill Clinton and his
team of idealistic foreign policy
officials helped make it happen just as
he promised Poland Hungary and the Czech
Republic all eventually joined the
alliance this was basically Russia's
worst nightmare but it couldn't do
anything about it the next round of NATO
expansion in 2004 added seven more
countries almost all had been part of
the Eastern Bloc the three Baltic
countries Estonia Latvia and Lithuania
were part of the Soviet Union itself now
they were part of the West at least in
geopolitical terms for Putin this shift
in the global order was part provocation
part existential threat NATO was
creeping up to his country's doorstep
which threatened to permanently relegate
Russia to the status of second tier
power in its own region it had to be
stopped Putin wanted to undermine NATO
and destabilize the U.S LED World Order
in his mind I'm sure he also wanted to
inflict some pain on the countries that
in his eyes had humiliated Russia at the
end of the Cold War but he knew there
was no way Russia could win a war
against NATO to achieve his goals Putin
would need to find another strategy in
late 2004 ukrainians went to the polls
to elect a president they weren't just
choosing between two guys with virtually
indistinguishable policies they were
choosing between two different visions
of what kind of country Ukraine should
be in one corner was the pro-russian
incumbent prime minister Victor
Yanukovych in the other Corner was the
pronato pro-eu opposition leader Victor
yoshenko the man who won would tilt
Ukraine closer to the west or closer to
Russia the future of the country was on
the line the Ukrainian Parliament had
already agreed to the formation of a
free trade zone with Russia Belarus and
Kazakhstan and Yanukovych had promised
to make Russian an official language in
Ukraine you better believe that Vladimir
Putin was watching closely the first
round of voting was held on October 31st
it was in incredibly tight because
neither candidate got more than 50
percent of the votes a runoff ballot was
held on November 21st to determine the
winner the result was still close but it
looked decisive Yanukovych got almost
900 000 more votes the geographic
distribution of the votes showed a clear
East-West division with voters in
Western Ukraine favoring yushenko and
those in eastern Ukraine favoring
Yanukovych from the first round to the
second round big increases in turnout
were recorded in regions that supported
Yanukovych in his home District the
turnout went up by more than 40 percent
some districts had the old Soviet
classic of more than 100 turnout
victoriouschenko was even Poisoned With
a toxic substance called dioxin he
survived but was permanently disfigured
International observers immediately
sounded the alarm and ukrainians took to
the streets on November the 22nd 2004
presidential election results were
announced in Ukraine they were greeted
with accusations of vote rigging on a
massive scale the defeated opposition
leader yoshenko called for a national
strike and the People's Army occupied
kef's main Square it was dubbed the
orange Revolution but it was the turning
point in a bruising election Marathon
Ukraine was electrified by acts of Civil
Disobedience sit-ins and general strikes
the protests worked Ukraine's Supreme
Court annulled the results of the runoff
and ordered another vote for December
26th the whole world was watching so
Yanukovych and Putin couldn't pull the
same tricks the final results showed a
clear victory for yoshenko who received
about 52 percent of the vote compared to
yanukovych's 45 on January 23 2005
Victor ushenko was inaugurated president
of Ukraine the orange Revolution is an
important chapter in the political
evolution of Vladimir Putin after years
of cementing his rule at home this was
the first time he interfered in the
politics of a neighboring country with
the goal of installing a pro-kremlin
regime and he failed but his failure
would only deepen his resolve to expand
Russia's sphere of influence couldn't
understood that in order to turn failure
into success he needed to silence his
enemies do you remember this man what
about when he looked like this that's
Alexander lid vignenko three days before
he died of polonium poisoning until 1998
he was a lieutenant colonel in the KGB
exactly the same rank as Vladimir Putin
but after giving a press conference
about an assassination plot he was fired
and then jailed for nine months when he
was released livinyenko fled Russia and
eventually settled in England there with
the help of another Exile the oligarch
Boris berezovsky he waged a years-long
media campaign against the Putin regime
they asked lots of uncomfortable
questions including about those
apartment bombings livignko was becoming
an annoyance so deep in the heart of the
Kremlin the decision was made to
eliminate him to Russian xkgb officers
were dispatched their destination London
they met with littmanyenko at the
Millennium Hotel on November 1st 2006.
that night he fell ill two days later he
was admitted to the hospital under a
fake name as his condition worsened he
told his doctors who he really was and
that he'd been poisoned testing of
lippanyenko's blood and urine detected
small gamma-ray spikes a scientist who'd
worked on Britain's early atomic bomb
program overheard a conversation and
recognized the gamma ray Spike as the
signature of polonium 210 but detecting
polonium was very different to treating
it U.S and UK government officials had
never heard a polonium being used as
poison before and no one could save
Alexander lippanyenko it took an
agonizing 23 days for him to die during
that time he wrote a statement blaming
Putin for what had happened
after his death investigators discovered
that the Assassins had put a lethal dose
of the polonium in a teapot at the
Millennium Hotel the assassination of
libyanco shook the world out of their
complacency regarding Putin as long as
he supported the war on terror and kind
of looked like a Democrat if you didn't
look too closely Western leaders could
convince themselves he was on their team
but now they could see the truth if
Putin could have one of his enemies
killed like that in a western Capital he
was capable of anything with the
assassination of Alexander livignko
Vladimir Putin showed everyone in the
west who he really was and the thing is
he was still a popular leader in Russia
lots of Russians still remembered the
Cold War and the shock therapy
administered by Western economists
throughout the 1990s to them Putin was
restoring Russia to its rightful place
as a world power in its own right and a
counterweight to the west in the United
States he was also growing the economy
the U.S invasion of Iraq was one of the
factors that led to a massive increase
in the price of oil and gas which the
Russian economy depended on between 2003
and mid-2008 the price of crude oil Rose
from thirty dollars per barrel to almost
150 dollars per barrel that translated
to Rapid economic growth Russia's GDP
grew by an average of seven percent per
year real disposable incomes doubled
Putin was helping Russians become
wealthier while also asserting their
interests abroad in early 2007 he
attended the Munich security conference
and gave a speech which would become a
major turning point in his rhetoric
toward the west in language that was
increasingly candid for such a setting
Putin accused the United States in the
west of arrogance hypocrisy and
violating democracy this is a world of
one Master One Sovereign they constantly
teach Russia thus democracy but those
who teach us for some reason do not
really want to learn this speech is
absolutely key to to understanding
Putin's worldview fifteen years before
he invaded Ukraine and five years before
Xi Jinping became the leader of China
Putin was telling the world that Russia
wanted a multi-polar world order in
other words he wanted a system that
represented capitalism democracy and
other Western values to become less
powerful the speech was music to the
ears of nationalists in Russia and
contributed to his popularity at home
there was just one hitch according to
Russia's Constitution he couldn't
actually serve a third term as president
so he hatched a scheme with his loyal
prime minister Dimitri Medvedev Medvedev
would become president and Putin would
serve as prime minister it was blatant's
subversion of democracy everyone could
see it was a way for Putin to maintain
his grip on Power and install someone
who would keep the seat warm for him
more than 71 percent of Russians voted
for Medvedev to become the figurehead
president despite no longer being
President Putin's grip on power was
stronger than ever and with things
secure at home he was ready to focus on
undermining these established world
order the leaders of NATO begin a
two-day Summit today that looks set to
highlight the pressures straining the
fabric of the alliance should NATO agree
to give membership action plans to
Georgia and Ukraine Russia was extremely
nervous about the prospect of countries
on its borders joining NATO which meant
that when NATO released a communique
which said that Ukraine and Georgia will
become members of NATO it immediately
set off alarm Bells those membership
action plans actually never ended up
happening but in Putin's eyes that
didn't matter from his perspective
allowing Ukraine and Georgia to join
NATO amounted to a direct threat to
Russia and he had to respond his first
Target was Georgia Georgia's pro-western
government was perpetually in conflict
with South osacha and abkezia two
Breakaway regions on its border with
Russia both regions which had lots of
native Russian speakers had declared
their independence most of the
International Community didn't recognize
those declarations but Russia did and
what's more Russia was providing
separatists in those regions with
weapons and other support the fighting
between Russia and Georgia over the
Georgian Breakaway region of South
osetia President Bush has told Russian
leaders that military action against
Georgia is unacceptable tensions reached
a Breaking Point on August 1 2008
separatist forces started shelling
Georgian Villages Georgia responded by
sending in the military to take control
of separatist town the Russian
government claimed falsely that Georgia
was committing genocide against South of
secha they used it as a pretext to
launch a full-scale Invasion including
into Undisputed Georgian territory
Russia's decisive military strength
meant the war was over in five days
Putin had sent a clear message to
Georgia and other countries in Eastern
Europe that were thinking about joining
NATO after failing to install his chosen
candidate in Ukraine the war against
Georgia showed that Putin was running a
different playbook in order to
destabilize a pro-western neighbor why
try and rig an election when you could
just arm separatists as an imperial
power Russia has always looked to
maintain spheres of influence on its
borders that's a big reason why as soon
as Putin saw there was a chance of
Georgia joining NATO he tried to depose
its president winning wars against small
countries was popular with Russians who
yearned for the good old days but there
were still lots of Russians who cared
about things like democracy and they
were about to make themselves heard tens
of thousands packed the streets of
Moscow and the biggest anti-government
demonstrations Russia has seen for 20
years they shouted Putin is a thief in
Russia without Putin protesters accused
prime minister Vladimir Putin in his
United Russia party of corruption and
rigging parliamentary elections last
weekend Russia's 2011 parliamentary
election had lots in common with the
Ukrainian presidential runoff that led
to the orange Revolution on top of
irregularities that Russians had grown
used to since Putin became leader like
debates between random candidates at 7am
cell phone footage showed blatant
violations of electoral laws videos were
quickly uploaded to social media India
which Putin didn't control at the time
people saw the evidence with their own
eyes but there was no way for the
election results to be overturned in
Ukraine the Supreme Court annulled the
result of the runoff but the same wasn't
going to happen in Russia Putin's party
United Russia maintained its
parliamentary majority more than a
hundred thousand brave people went out
onto the streets they weren't just
protesting the election results they
were protesting that their country had
been turned into a dictatorship
presidential elections were due in early
2012. everyone knew Putin would get his
old job back his preferred candidate
Victor Yanukovych was even back as
president of Ukraine Russian Civil
Society may have been defiant but the
country's institutions and political
opposition had been totally neutralized
Putin could only see one threat to his
rule Putin built his own anxieties into
his 2012 presidential campaign he
compared the political situation in
Russia to Napoleon's attempted Invasion
200 years earlier and said that National
sovereignty was Paramount he got almost
two-thirds of the votes from a tired and
defeated electorate and just like that
he was president again
it sounds weird but Putin's most
important political victory of 2012
didn't happen in Moscow it happened
three and a half thousand miles away in
Beijing Xi Jinping and Vladimir Putin
have a lot in common they're just six
months apart in age their fathers both
fought in World War II they met at an
economic cooperation Summit in 2013. the
day they met was actually Putin's
birthday Xi Jinping presented him with a
cake while the Russian president pulled
out a bottle of vodka as far as we can
tell they've actually become friends
poon was the first world leader that Xi
Jinping visited after becoming China's
president and they've had more than 40
meetings since then most importantly
their allies with a common geopolitical
goal creating a multi-polar world order
C came along at the perfect time for
Putin on its own Russia can't take on
NATO or the United States its military
isn't strong enough its economy isn't
big enough and its diplomacy isn't
effective enough
China might be different from as soon as
he gained power Xi Jinping has made it
clear that his ultimate foreign policy
aim is to displace the United States as
the world's most powerful country put in
wants to weaken the West while expanding
Russia's sphere of influence it was the
beginning of an important partnership
Vladimir Putin survived massive protests
at home and brushed off criticism from
the International Community his Rivals
were sidelined and his critics were dead
in jail or in Exile he was further
annoying the west by supporting the
Syrian president Bashar al-assad in the
Civil War that had engulfed the country
there were even Whispers that he had
secretly become one of the world's
richest men by embezzling money and
extorting the country's oligarchs he had
achieved absolute power at home and in
Xi Jinping he had a powerful new ally
but the mission he had been training for
decades had only really just started
because as Putin began his third term as
president in 2012 he was still missing
the biggest piece of the puzzle Ukraine
why is Ukraine so important for Putin
because it matters to Russia's past and
its future let me explain Ukraine has
been Central to Russian identity and
power for centuries Christianity was in
poor from Byzantium to the Slavic people
via Kiev and Christianity served as the
anchor for Kevin Roos the early state
from which Russians ukrainians and
belarussians draw their cultural lineage
today those close links have remained
most ukrainians can speak at least some
Russian and Eastern Ukraine was
historically home to a large ethnic
Russian minority Ukraine was also
strategically vital for Russian
interests as Europe's second largest
country it contributed massive amounts
of grain coal and steel to the Soviet
Union Ukrainian factories were a vital
part of the ussr's military-industrial
capacity Russian Czar spent their
Summers on the beautiful beaches of the
Crimean Peninsula which also hosted the
country's largest warm water Naval port
and through to the modern day Ukraine's
location on the Black Sea and on the
border with numerous Eastern European
States and future NATO members was vital
to Russian interests the countries have
been so closely intertwined throughout
history that most Russian nationalists
Putin included don't actually think
Ukraine is a separate country Putin even
wrote an entire essay about it in 2021
Putin believed that Russians and
ukrainians were single people United by
history and divided by a meddling West
the vast majority of ukrainians
disagreed but Putin has made a career
out of not caring what people think
losing Ukraine had undermined Russian
power losing it permanently to the
Westwood in Putin's eyes be a major
ongoing threat to Russian security the
air needed to be corrected a miracle
didn't happen and European union leaders
and Ukraine have as expected failed to
sign an historic free trade deal after a
last-minute U-turn from Kiev on November
21st 2013 a week before The Summit in
Lithuania Yanukovych announced he
wouldn't sign it who knows what exactly
made him change his mind but the U-turn
made millions of ukrainians realize that
so long as their government was taking
orders from Moscow they could never be
truly free to be free they needed a
revolution
[Music]
hundreds of thousands took to the
streets across Ukraine kiev's
Independent Square was turned into a
massive protest camp with barricades
broadcasting facilities and stages for
lectures and speeches events escalated
further in early 2014 when Yanukovych
signed Draconian anti-protest laws but
that couldn't stop the protesters even
when Security Forces started firing
killing almost a hundred of them they
didn't stop they wanted Yanukovych out
they soon got their wish the anakovich
fled and it didn't surprise anyone when
he resurfaced days later in Russia the
Ukrainian Parliament restored the
Constitution to its 2004 version an
interim government signed the EU deal a
former businessman became president the
events of February 2014 became known in
Ukraine as the revolution of dignity the
future of Ukraine suddenly looked bright
but Vladimir Putin wasn't about to
accept defeat soldiers began appearing
in the southern Ukrainian province of
Crimea and they came to be known as The
Little Green Men within a couple of
weeks the whole of Crimea was under the
control of these little green men for
weeks Putin denied these little green
men were Russian soldiers claiming
instead they were local militia who'd
seized Ukrainian weapons eventually he
couldn't deny the obvious they were
Russian soldiers although Putin didn't
admit it some of the soldiers weren't
fighting under the Russian flag some
were mercenaries under the command of
Evgeni pregosian a businessman known as
Putin's Chef because he ran a catering
business which staged Banquets for the
Kremlin and now those mercenaries
together with the Russian soldiers and
the rest of the little green men were
occupying the territory of a foreign
country Crimea had been one of the most
prized possessions of the Russian Empire
and Soviet Union but in 1954 the leader
of the USSR Nikita Khrushchev
transferred control of Crimea to Ukraine
partly to commemorate the 300th
anniversary of Ukraine's Union with
Russia Ukraine was part of the Soviet
Union so as long as the Soviet Union
existed it didn't really matter too much
but of course the Soviet Union collapsed
and suddenly Crimea belonged to a
different country that was terrible news
for nationalists like Putin to them
Crimea was part of Russia but during the
1990s and 2000s Not only was Russia too
weak to try and take it back it didn't
have the right opportunity Ukraine's
revolution of dignity changed that it
created a power vacuum which allowed
Putin to run a version of the same
Playbook that he'd employed in Georgia
six years before on March 6th the
Crimean Parliament which remembered the
little green men had actually occupied
voted to hold a snap referendum on
Independence and the prospect of joining
Russia 97 percent of crimeans said they
were in favor of joining Russia it's
absolutely true that there was genuine
support for Russia especially in the
Southern and Eastern regions of Ukraine
where cultural ties to Russia were
stronger but I'll leave it up to you to
decide if the vote was totally fair or
not it didn't matter Putin had his
pretext soldiers this time bearing the
official Insignia of the Russian
military moved in they quickly
surrounded all of Ukraine's military
bases in the region and on the 18th
Putin announced the formal incorporation
of Crimea into Russia it's not like
anyone was under any illusion about
Vladimir Putin but even by those
standards this was an escalation the
annexation of Crimea was the first time
a European country seized territory for
another European country in the 21st
century it was a shock to everyone who
had kind of assumed that war in Europe
was the thing of the past from there
things moved really fast armed
pro-russian separatists in the provinces
of Donetsk in luhansk an area
collectively known as the donbass
declared independence from Ukraine and
the fighting began Russia covertly
provided the separatists with weapons
while massing thousands of soldiers on
Ukraine's eastern border by the end of
April Ukraine had lost control of
Donetsk and luhansk to the separatists
International authorities warned
commercial airlines to not fly over
eastern Ukraine but tragically the
warning came too late the terrible first
moment after flight mh-17 was shot down
local villagers struggled to prevent the
fires spreading to their crops the
shooting down of Malaysian Airlines
flight 17 made everyone in the world
realize that they had to pay attention
to what was happening in the donbass
until then lots of people could convince
themselves that it didn't really matter
it was just fighting in a far away place
they hadn't heard of but this was a
passenger plane with casualties from 10
different countries and when
investigators learned that the plane had
been shot down by pro-russian
separatists using a service-to-air
missile which they had imported from
Russia the International Community was
outraged it was a very tense moment
world wars have been started over less
thankfully the moment passed without
further escalation all sides Ukraine
Russia and the two so-called people's
republics agreed on a road map to ending
the war in late 2019. it quickly failed
mostly because of repeated breaches by
the Russian side but that's exactly how
Putin wanted it he didn't want to end
the fighting deep in the heart of the
Kremlin isolated from his advisors
because of his paranoia about covid-19
Vladimir Putin decided that he would
finally undo the catastrophe brought
about by the collapse of the Soviet
Union he would invade Ukraine and
reattach it to Russia by force most
people at least in the west never
believed he'd do it they thought it was
an irrational move that would only serve
to galvanize the west and push Ukraine
toward NATO but he did it anyway on
February 24th 2022 after weeks of
preparation Russian troops crossed
Ukraine's northern border including from
neighboring Belarus from Donetsk in
luhansk in the East and from the South
Via Crimea see
footage captured some of the first
moments of the invasion it wasn't the
beginning of a war it was the escalation
of one which began when those little
green men started showing up in Crimea
and of course according to Putin it was
not a war at all it was a special
military operation no one knows how the
war in Ukraine will end but in many ways
it's already been a failure Putin
expected Ukraine and the West to
collapse Ukraine itself has been
incredibly resilient and almost a
quarter of a century after the cursed
disaster Russia has shown surprising
weakness in terms of tactics and
hardware and rather than quickly seizing
Ukraine Putin has massively increased
the importance of NATO and brought the
West into the closest security
partnership it's had for decades Finland
has joined NATO it looks like Sweden
will join soon too and there are serious
discussions underway about Ukraine
joining as well Putin's Invasion has
drawn clear battle lines on one side
there's the West a grouping which now
includes Ukraine and on the other side
there's Russia China and their allies
less than three weeks before Russia
invaded Ukraine Putin visited Beijing
there he signed what China called a No
Limits partnership since the invasion
began Chinese officials have been
careful to not refer to it as a war
while also repeating Putin's narrative
that NATO expansion was to blame the two
countries have deepened their
cooperation in several areas China is
now Russia's number one trading partner
and has propped up Russia's economy by
buying their oil natural gas and
advanced weapon systems
conduct joint military exercises on a
near-monthly basis and their generals
regularly discuss how to overcome
strategic threats such as U.S nuclear
modernization and missile defense in
March 2023 Xi Jinping visited Russia to
see Vladimir Putin for the first time
since the Invasion the two men pledged
to shape a new world order and drive
changes not seen in a century it sounds
like their friendship is going pretty
well in addition to changing Global
geopolitics Putin's Invasion has also
changed Russia as the war started to
drag on and the easy victory that Putin
expected didn't materialize key Russian
military leaders began grumbling one of
the loudest critics was someone I
mentioned earlier Putin's Chef evgeny
pagosian pagosian runs the Wagner group
a shadowy mercenary organization that
first appeared in Crimea in 2014 but
since then has exerted Russian influence
by proxy in places like Syria Libya and
Mali and since late 2022 he's been
saying what everyone in the Russian army
is scared to say the war is going badly
in October he criticized the decision to
withdraw from a key City in eastern
Ukraine in February of 2023 he recorded
messages on telegram accusing Russia's
most senior General and the country's
defense minister of withholding
ammunition and supplies from his
soldiers so of treason basically and in
early June he said the Wagner group
wouldn't sign a contract with the
defense Ministry but I think it's fair
to say that no one expected the
escalation that happened on June 23rd in
a half hour video pagosian directly
accused the Russian military of
attacking Wagner's fighters in Ukraine
while also directly contradicting all of
Putin's justifications for the war
saying the war wasn't needed to return
Russian citizens to our bosom nor to
demilitarize or denotsify Ukraine the
war was needed so that a bunch of
animals could simply exult in glory but
this time pagosian wouldn't just settle
for talking he directed his fighters to
go on the offensive within hours they
had captured major military buildings in
rustavondan Russia's ninth largest city
and a major staging point for The
Invasion and an armored column was
moving in the direction of Moscow
unconfirmed reports even suggested that
the Wagner group shot down several
Russian military aircraft Putin quickly
mobilized troops to defend the capital
and gave a speech calling the Rebellion
a knife in the back plane tracking data
suggested that the presidential plane
flew North out of Moscow before
switching off its transponder and going
dark and then just as quickly as the
Rebellion or Mutiny or coup whatever you
want to call it had started it was over
the president of Belarus Alexander
lukashenko said he struck a deal to end
the conflict and provide pagosian with
Safe Harbor in Belarus as one tweet put
it the Wagner Rebellion is like if a
bunch of disgruntled Blackwater vets
took San Diego except it's even worse
because then the Blackwater vets made it
almost all the way to Washington DC
before Joe Biden cut a deal with Justin
Trudeau to take in their leader while
also dropping all criminal charges was
it an attempted coup was it just a feud
between different factions did pagosian
get some kind of deal in exchange for
turning his soldiers around how much
will this help Ukraine as I'm recording
this there aren't really any clear
answers but it's safe to say one thing
it's really bad news for Vladimir Putin
his former Ally publicly called the war
corrupt revealed massive problems inside
of Russia's military and then seized one
of the country's most important cities
almost without a fight and all Putin
could do was give a speech and then
seemingly let him Escape without
punishment almost 25 years after he
climbed to the top of Russian politics
maybe the world is now seeing another
side of Vladimir Putin the leader who's
losing control at the start of this
video I asked some questions like who is
Vladimir Putin what does he want and why
did he invade Ukraine Vladimir Putin is
a spy politician Nationalist and a
gangster Who Wants to Be an emperor he's
also one of the most important people in
the world and every day since he started
as a junior KGB officer he's been on a
mission to restore Russia's standing as
a world power and in the process to
weaken the West
so far he's mostly failed Russia is
still in Decline and he can't do much
about it his invasion of Ukraine has
brought the West as close as it's been
for decades and the Wagner group's
Rebellion has shown that his grip on
power may be more tenuous than it's ever
been but he's found an incredibly
important Ally Xi Jinping their
friendship is a big problem for everyone
who cares about democracy human rights
and a stable International system and it
might end up being the most important
part of Vladimir Putin's Legacy and to
better understand this Dynamic you need
to watch this video about Xi Jinping
next thanks a lot